j'ai une idée j'ai une idée j'ai pensé à
un truc ça va être cool
[Musique]
et salue les gens à l'écran c'est
françois pour la chaîne explique pas
encore je suis ravi de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui on va faire un truc nouveau
sur la chaîne j'ai eu une idée hier soir
je me suis dit tiens ça va être sympa ça
va vous apprendre des trucs et en plus
on va pouvoir jouer un petit peu tout au
long de la vidéo donc ça va être plutôt
cool alors je vous explique 2 1 je pars
en tournage et aujourd'hui je vais
préparer mon matos egypte plutôt
batailler pour choisir ce que j'allais à
mener ou pas parce que ça va être dans
des conditions un petit peu particulière
ce tournage ça va être un tirage un peu
compliqué et je me suis dit que j'allais
vous expliquer les raisons pour
lesquelles j'avais choisi tel ou tel
matos sans vous dire où se passera le
tournage et quel type de tournage ce
sera mais je vais vous donner des petits
indices tout au long et à la fin de la
vidéo je vous montrerai des petits
extraits puisque je vais monter cette
vidéo youtube après avoir fait le
tournage de demain c'est ça va vous
suivez donc n'hésitez pas quand vous
pensez avoir une petite idée du type de
tournage que ça va être à me mettre un
petit commentaire et tester un petit peu
voir si vous avez la bonne réponse aux
gens que la bonne réponse je la donnerai
dans tous les cas à la fin alors
première chose c'est choisir la caméra
voilà donc j'ai deux options vous savez
j'ai les séries z de nikon et j'ai
l'arrêt de komodo donc la question qui
se pose c'est laquelle je vais utiliser
aujourd'hui alors c'est un tournage sur
lequel je vais avoir relativement le
temps sur lequel je vais avoir du
contrôle sur la lumière donc
techniquement quelque chose d'assez
posais déjà peut-être petite idée sur le
type de tournage que ça va idéalement
partirai sur la red elle est moins run
and gun que le z mais la sica le raid
code tout ça il ya quand même une
qualité assez ouf sauf que ah bah non je
vais partir sur le z ou simplement parce
que dans l'endroit où je vais aller
shooter il ya un très très très fort
taux d'humidité voire même des gouttes
qui peuvent tomber des gouttes d'eau
donc la red n'étant pas tropicalisé on
peut voir même là dessus je peux vous
montrer voilà ici on voit carrément
l'intérieur de la caméra il ya les
ventilateurs et tout est absolument pas
fait pour aller sous la flotte alors que
le z lui il est totalement tropicalisé
donc on va pas le mettre dans l'eau mais
techniquement il est censé résister à
l'humidité donc c'est pour ça que j'ai
choisi de partir sur le z mais
évidemment la contrepartie c'est que la
qualité d'image bruch du set 6-2 et de
l'arrêt de komodo c'est pas du tout du
tout du tout la même chose pour remédier
à ça j'ai pris l'enregistreur black
magic pour faire du bio puisque les eti
ce j'avais fait une vidéo qui s'affiche
ici peut faire en externe du bureau le
bureau qui est quand même assez proche
du raid connaître bien évidemment je dis
pas que l'enregistrement black magic et
l'arrêt de komodo c'est la même chose
mais on est déjà sur quelque chose de
bien plus qualitatif que le codec
interne du set 6 2 et puis surtout on va
avoir toute la gestion des méta data
dans davinci résolve à pouvoir gérer les
iso en post prod la balance des blancs
si jamais il ya un truc qui va pas et
c'est ma petite inquiétude c'est que bah
ça par contre c'est pas tropicalisé donc
ce que je vais faire c'est le monte au
dernier moment et puis surtout à partir
du moment où je vais ouvrir ouvrir la
petite trappe ici si j'y arrive l'ajout
montre si ça veut bien faire le focus
encore une fois
la voilà la petite trappe ou ya le hdmi
est bien parti au moment où j'ai ouvert
ça c'est plus vraiment étanche le but du
jeu de ces trappes l'asse d'être étanche
donc je sortirai mon enregistreur au
dernier moment vous avez vu qu'ici j'ai
un petit une petite griffe paul ring qui
normalement est fait pour mettre des
batteries moi j'y mets tout simplement
le disque dur externe un petit samsung
t3 qui va servir pour enregistrer le
bureau puisque on ne peut pas
l'enregistrer dans l'ain leurs
enregistreurs on va l'enregistrer
directement sur le ssd le mettre
directement sur ordinateur après comme
vous pouvez le voir également j'ai fixé
le moniteur sur une petite poignée small
rig ici pour pouvoir ensuite porté le
zi6 plus facilement et est venu ensuite
la question de la stabilisation parce
que à main levée on peut faire des trucs
cool mais pour ce que je vais faire
c'est pas forcément l'idéal alors au
départ bougez pas au départ j'étais
parti sur ça c'est à dire le craignent 3
s j'avais fait une vidéo dessus
d'ailleurs le lien sa fiche là dessus
c'est un guignol qui est très lourd mais
qui aussi est très stable alors là
dessus c'est pareil j'ai un petit bras
pour fixer si je veux un enregistreur
ici directement le truc c'est qu'il va y
avoir un petit peu de marche pour
arriver sur le lieu du tournage et que
idéalement
l'idée c'est d'amener tout le matériel
sur place en une fois
[Musique]
et pas à les faire de l'aller retour
jusqu'à la voiture ou un autre endroit
et ce guignol il est quand même
vachement lourd et le gain de
stabilisation par rapport à ce que j'ai
vraiment choisi c'est pas non plus a
donc ici j'ai privilégié quelque chose
de léger le plus léger possible parce
que c'est sûr que j'ai accessoirisé donc
du coup le cren 3 s il va rester à la
maison gentiment et à la place et à la
place hommes
j'ai pris mon petit ring et paul voilà
vous voyez que j'ai monté le set 6-2
directement dessus alors oui ce rig
épaules on me l'a fait remarquer pas
très gentiment récemment il est hyper
cheap c'est un reggae paul newer avec
ici juste j'ai acheté le coup ci n'est
là pour l'épaule qui est un small rig
c'est pas fou fou ça coûte pas très cher
mais ça marche bien les poignées ici une
fois que c'est bien serré ça ne bouge
pas les roses ils ont fixé la ne bouge
pas non plus pour ce que je veux en
faire à savoir ça ça va très bien du
coup pouvait remarquer un petit truc
aussi sur ma cage la up j'ai ce petit
truc là qui va me permettre de faire
quelque chose d'assez cool à savoir que
si je monte mon disque dur ici la
branche et il faut mettre évidemment une
ou plusieurs batteries on en met de
l'aop bien vie c'est pour ça que ça se
casse la gueule voilà je peux tout
simplement venir accrocher up ici voilà
j'ai accroché mon moniteur sa batterie
le disque dur ici et ça me permet aussi
d'avoir une autre prise au fil mais
aussi comme ça ce ça me permet d fois
d'avoir un peu plus de prises et de
moins souffrir quand je le porte à bout
de bras et surtout si vous vous rappelez
l'idée c'est aussi de pouvoir enlever
cette partie là le plus rapidement
possible pour qu'elle reste le moins
possible à l'humidité est juste de
dévisser et je peux ranger ça dans mon
sac pour le mettre à l'abri si jamais il
ya un petit peu trop d'humidité là on
n'est déjà pas mal et là aussi ça a été
un dilemme dernière chose c'est les
optiques que je vais prendre alors qui
dit humidité dit qu'on va essayer au
maximum de ne pas interchangeables les
optiques pendant le tournage sauf que ce
tournage il va se dérouler en très basse
lumière donc j'ai besoin d'optique qui
ouvre grand est clairement les zooms que
j'ai à savoir le 14 24 et le 24 70 il
aura 2 8 et 2 8 ce sera pas suffisant je
le sais me suis regardé j'ai vu des
images de l'endroit où on va tourner
donc ce qu'on fera c'est qu'on changera
les optiques quand tu auras besoin avec
marie en mode plaque lac tient que la
claque tient aux finis on n'en parle
plus pour essayer de faire en sorte
qu'il y ait le minimum d'humidité qui
rentre dans une optique voire pas du
tout et encore moins sur le capteur un
bien évidemment mais là on fera hyper
attention donc je prends pour aller sur
ce tournage le 35 mm qui est fixé sur la
caméra qui est juste là laquelle je
parle voilà je prends également le 50
millions
pas du tout je me prend absolument pas
le 50 je prends également le 24 mm f/1 8
qui est sûre cette caméra là et enfin je
prends le 85 mm f/1 8 toujours qui est
ici donc c'est les optiques prime nicor
donc pour récapituler un petit peu les
questionnements sur ce que je prends
avant de partir en tournage première
chose que vous montrez c est ce que ça
va être du run and gun du reportage où
il va falloir aller très vite ou est-ce
que ça va être quelque chose de plus
posé si c'est plus posé je prends la
caméra qui a les meilleures capacités
même si elle est moins pratique à
utiliser il faut que là en l'occurence
j'ai besoin de la tropicalisation du z
et c'est là que j'ai quand même
vachement content ne pas avoir que la
red pour le coup j'ai été hyper emmerder
j'aurais pas pu faire ce tournage si je
me pose la question du mode
d'enregistrement à savoir ce que je vais
enregistrer en interne ou en externe
selon la qualité que je veux donner à
mon projet si vous l'avez vu aussi une
histoire de poids est ce que le poids de
mon read peux me pénaliser sur ce
tournage ici aussi clairement c'est un
oui donc je pars sur le reggae paul qui
est beaucoup plus léger que le
stabilisateur que j'ai et enfin les
optiques là je vais filmer en basse
lumière donc j'ai besoin d'avoir mes
optique qui ouvre le plus grand possible
un dernier point qu'on n'a pas abordé
ces leçons comme vous avez vu j'ai pas
équipés de micros j'ai pas monter le
socle des picots mag déjà parce que je
les utilise là mais je ne vais pas les
amener à ce qui ne va pas de prise de
son sur ce tournage enfin pas de prise
de sang que je vais garder je vais
enregistrer le son avec le boîtier pour
avoir un son témoin mais aura un autre
son pardessus donc là déjà je pense que
vous pouvez imaginer et dire dans les
commentaires ce que vous pensez que ça
va être juste avant de vous mettre
l'extrait du tournage pour voir si vous
aviez raison si vous aviez trouvé le
type de tournage que j'allais faire je
vous encourage à mettre le coup de
blaster sur le pouce en l'air qui se
situe juste en dessous de cette vidéo si
elle vous a plu à vous abonner si ce
n'est pas déjà le cas et puis moi je
vous dise me rester curieux et à très
bientôt pour une prochaine vidéo
attention extraits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on doit